resuelva el triángulo rectángulo que se
muestra a continuación y de las
longitudes en la décima más cercana
podemos ver este triángulo que conocemos
este lado también tenemos este ángulo de
65 grados y conocemos este ángulo x
porque es el ángulo recto de 90 grados
nos falta por conocer la longitud del
lado a la longitud del lado b y el
ángulo doble pero como tenemos estos
datos no debe ser difícil resolverlo hay
muchas maneras de encontrar esto aquí
vamos a resolver primero el lado a que
es el segmento de w x una pista pueden
usar una calculadora y las identidades
trigonométricas para resolverla les daré
algunos segundos para que piensen en
cómo pueden resolver esto
qué es lo que conocemos vemos que este
lado es el lado opuesto al ángulo que
conocemos aquí de 65 grados y también
conocemos el lado adyacente de este
ángulo que vemos es el valor 5 que
identidad trigonométricas nos involucra
el lado o el cateto adyacente y el
cateto opuesto si no recuerdan las
definiciones pues vamos a usar el mónico
zocato son
y quedamos que este va a ser el cateto
adyacente adyacente lo abrevió aquí y
éste
es el cateto opuesto
involucra el cateto adyacente y el
cateto opuesto a pues es este toda la
tangente así que podemos decir que la
tangente
tangente de 65 grados es igual al lado
al lado opuesto que es
entre el cateto adyacente que vale 5
lo que podemos hacer es despejar al que
es el valor que nos interesa y vamos a
multiplicar 5 en ambos lados de la
ecuación así que aquí multiplico 5 por
tangente de 65 y aquí 5 por a entre 5
estos dos se me van a cancelar y me va a
quedar que a es igual a 5 por tangente
de 65 grados
vamos a usar nuestra calculadora para
encontrar el valor de esta tangente de
65 grados nos aseguramos estar en el
modo de grados y escribimos 65 y
elegimos la tangente y nos queda que es
2.14 45 esto lo vamos a multiplicar por
5 para encontrar el valor de a por 5 es
igual a 10 puntos 72 pero como nos están
pidiendo que demos las longitudes en la
décima más cercana lo vamos a redondear
a 10.7 nos va a quedar que a es
aproximadamente igual
a 10.7 escribimos el valor de ha
encontrado es aproximadamente igual a
10.7
hay varias maneras de encontrarme
ustedes pueden elegir el método que más
les guste y yo también me pregunto a
ustedes es como encontramos el valor del
segmento wv o cuál es el valor de ver ya
que ve es la hipotenusa podríamos usar
las igualdades trigonométricas con el
opuesto entre la hipotenusa o el
adyacente entre la hipotenusa o podemos
usar el teorema de pitágoras conocemos
ambos lados de este triángulo rectángulo
que al sumar al cuadrado de cada uno de
estos tendríamos el cuadrado de la
hipotenusa yo en particular usaré las
igualdades trigonométricas este lado b
es la hipotenusa la voy a abreviar
de hipotenusa
podemos usar esta igualdad de seno igual
a opuesto entre hipotenusa o adyacente
entre hipotenusa que sería el coseno ya
que sabemos que este lado mide
exactamente 5 no tenemos que estar con
aproximaciones pues vamos a elegir el
coseno que es el lado adyacente entre la
hipotenusa vamos a poner entonces el
coseno del ángulo que es de 65 grados es
igual al cateto adyacente que vale 5
entre la hipotenusa que es el lado b y
que aún no conozco y es el valor que me
interesa vamos a despejar b que es el
valor que me interesa y voy a
multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación x
aquí también me quedaba por coseno de 65
grados es igual estos dos se cancelan a
5 y divido a ambos lados de la ecuación
entre cocina de 65 grados así que aquí
es uno entre coseno de 65 grados
y uno / coseno de 65 grados
esto lo hago con el fin de tener esta
vez solita me va a quedar que ve ya que
estos dos se van a cancelar va a ser
igual a 5 entre el coseno de 65 grados
con seno de 65 grados sacamos de nuevo
nuestra calculadora
5 x y entre paréntesis
1 /
el coseno de 65 grados cierre paréntesis
doy igual y me queda el valor de 11.83
como me piden la décima más cercana voy
a redondear lo a 11.8
este lado va a ser aproximadamente igual
a 11.8 lo escribo acá
este valor este lado es 11.8
aproximadamente y solo me restaría
encontrar el ángulo w
les voy a dar unos minutos para que
ustedes piensen cómo encontrarlo
aquí tenemos que recordar que la suma de
los ángulos internos de un triángulo
siempre nos va a dar 180 grados por lo
que tenemos este ángulo recto de 90
grados 90 grados más este ángulo de 65
grados 65 grados más el ángulo w que es
el que queremos conocer más w esta es
una base de igual a 180 grados
vamos 90 65 y nos queda 155
+ w igual a 180 vamos a despejar w que
es lo que me interesa por lo que voy a
restar ambos lados de la ecuación con
menos 155
y el resto menos 155 y aquí también
menos 155 aquí estos dos se van a
cancelar me va a quedar w es igual a 180
menos 155 va a ser 25 wv este ángulo w
es igual a 25 grados
y con eso terminamos todo lo que nos
solicitan en este problema